je résume vrai par formidable
immense haut
créatif et un grand sens de l'humour
e
apple guy hever je suis maître verrier
je suis un artiste créateur peu importe
la matière avec tout ce qui touche tout
ce qui bouge pas
genia 1133 je n'ai vu que personne
n'arrive à prononcer parce que les gens
sympas fianarantsoa
je faisais la décoration moi j'ai des
décorateurs des bénédictins greffer un
atelier du trail est une dame qui avait
refusé une maquette que les parties ont
maintenant j'ai travaillé comme
maquettiste je faisais ma maquette au
10e qui des registres produits en grand
pour les réalisations tant enseignante
au collège du bnq à un jour j'ai
organisé une exposition sur les artistes
de l'ouest pour faire connaître ces
artistes aux élèves que moi je n'ai pas
rencontré un sculpteur nude
artiste mais un homme avec qui je me
suis bien entendu donc ce n'est pas son
travail de créateurs qui m'a
spécialement inspiré au départ on a
envie de transformer quelque chose alors
c'est un tuyau de gouttière mais moi
j'ai dans mes seins en dames guy lit son
journal voilà c'est amusant de tous y a
pas de désir de faire passer quelque
chose
voici une ancienne voisine qui est allé
un peu plus loin et puis c'est un peu
plus loin un jour m'a dit qu'il y avait
un aviez qui se libérer à l'époque et
pas comme ça avait une grande même pas
une rue un grand passage en terre battue
qui a contribué en fait
affaire de l'éperon un village en tisane
parce qu'il crée parce qu'il a un
atelier parce qu'on peut visiter que
s'est ouvert ce accessible
tous
il va passer beaucoup de temps à ne rien
faire à se concentrer à réfléchir
c'est venu comme une aspiration de cours
sur son camp j'ai un travail à faire
j'ai dans un endroit je m'assois j'ai
réfléchi à ce qui pourrait aller dans
ces endroits et jamais copié collé
où
à une association qui s'est créée les
amis de guy lefebvre
le but principal est de faire un livre
peau qu'ils soient connus que les gens
aient un système de référence c'est le
seul maître verrier de l'océan indien
il a oeuvré énormément sur la réunion il
a fait à peu près toutes les églises la
cathédrale tous les édifices religieux
et aussi des des projets civils comme
dans les usines avoir du boulot mais au
lieu de laisser vide parce que les
hublots été fait pour qu'il y ait une
ventilation nous ici on a mis le soleil
et la lune des symboles de la vie il a
oeuvré à la réunion depuis 1967 il a
oeuvré dans l'océan indien parce qu'il a
travaillé à madagascar et à maurice
depuis donc avant 1967 à madagascar et
qu'il a laissé des oeuvres marquantes
elle y croit oui elle et par elle
appelle un film commercial mais yannick
roy c'est important pour elle bah je
pense qu'elle même chose avec ça fait
plaisir mais sans plus le jeu je veux
pas m'impliquer adam c'est pas possible
parce que
ça serait plutôt gênant que des récentes
dont les autres
pensez à à pois l'elysée a été voué pour
rappeler pourquoi à chaque fois que ça
vient d'où l'inspiration à ça ça vient
de trouver gmao
regardant les choses qui plus ou moins
belles ils sont en fait on on s'enrichit
façon il faut aller le chercher je pense
que c'est la qualité des grands artistes
c'est de travailler sur tout ce qui
compte pour lui c'est de réussir sa vie
c'est pas de s'exposer d'avoir la gloire
je vous souhaite plein de reconnaissance
en fait plus de reconnaissance de
continuer à créer si ça a fait son
bonheur pour obtenir une retraite il
faut avoir cotisé vendre un temps donné
à une caisse qui vous reverse après
votre argent et moi jamais fait donc je
veux rester un artiste coffre non je
plaisante